A study by Stanford university revealed that
in the US alone 3.5 million children and teenagers
are injured playing sports each year.
But that figure is far greater in other parts
of the world, where things are a little less
"regulated", and sports tend to get a lot
more messy.
Here's the world's top 10 most dangerous sports.
First up is bull running.
Known as The Running of the Bulls or encierro.
This insane sport usually takes place down
the quaint, peaceful, and extremely narrow
backstreets of towns and cities all across
Spain.
Before the bull run commences a large crowd
of people gathers along a narrow backstreet,
then an angry herd of stampeding bulls is
let loose at one end of the street and charges
down it, mowing down any adrenaline pumped
Spaniard with a death wish who happens to
get in their way.
The participants run in front of the bulls
and the goal of this sport is to basically
avoid receiving a nasty bludgeoning of bull's
horn where the sun don't shine.
The most popular bull run happens every year
in Pamplona, in northern Spain.
Every year around 300 brave amigos are injured
at the event, mostly due to contusions from
being knocked over.
Since 1910, 14 people have been killed during
Pamplona's running of the bulls.
Imagine if someone told you that they like
to lie flat on a wooden board with wheels
on it and go hurtling down a steep road with
only their feet to use as brakes.
You would probably think they're two trucks
short of a skateboard.
Well a surprising amount of people actually
enjoy risking their lives, and doing just
that.
It's a sport known as Street Luge and it's
similar to skateboarding except the board
is slightly longer and the rider is required
to be in a supine position on their luge board,
which basically means lying down, face up.
Oh and to top it all off, participants of
this sport sometimes go down public roads,
with actual cars on them.
When you consider that the rider's visual
profile is only a few inches from the road's
surface, you can probably imagine the enormous
risks involved.
If you think that's scary, it gets worse,
street lugers can reach speed of up to 97
mph.
That's considerably faster than a car travelling
on a freeway or motorway.
Because the rider's own legs and feet are
the only thing that they can use as breaks,
broken legs or torn ligaments are common in
street luging as well as other, more serious
injuries.
One can only imagine the surprise and horror
of the first ever person to partake in street
luging, when they realised half way down their
descent that their only brakes were their
own feet.
Needless to say, they probably had a bad time.
Next up is the Vietnamese sport of Hoi Phet.
It's a tradition in the village of Hien Quan,
north of Hanoi.
Each year thousands of villagers gather on
a sand dune and fight over a painted red ball
using sticks.
If it sounds primitively violent, that's because
it is.
The villagers believe that the ball will bring
them good luck in the new year, if they don't
get their front teeth knocked out trying to
retrieve it.
At first glance it may seem awfully similar
to hockey, but there are two major differences.
The sticks are considerably cruder and more
substantial and it's a hell of a lot more
violent.
The participants are allowed to swing their
huge lumps of curved wood at anything or anyone
that gets in the way of the ball.
Needless to say, injuries are common and blood
is frequently spilt.
Funny how hitting people with sticks is not
okay, but add a ball and hey!
Suddenly it's a sport.
If you thought hitting people with sticks
sounds violent, how about hitting people with
sticks whilst hurling balls at them?
That's pretty much the idea behind Lacrosse.
Lacrosse is similar to football or basketball
but with long sticks with nets on the end,
oh and there's an awful lot more contact and
general violent tendencies between players.
Lacrosse isn't a commonly played sport because
it takes tough and fearless individuals to
play it at a competitive level.
When it comes to rough contact the rules are
more relaxed with Lacrosse than other sports.
Players are permitted to hit and tackle the
opponents with some considerable force that
would be illegal in most other contact sports.
Broken bones, punctured lungs and other serious
injuries are highly common in Lacrosse.
Very similar to Lacrosse is a sport called
Irish hurling, which is like lacrosse, but
with axe-shaped wooden sticks, minimal padding
for the players, and it's considerably faster,
in fact is officially the world's fastest
field sport, enough to make a lacrosse player
shake in their shin guards.
Now this next sport involves a bunch of eccentric
cheese lovers who've all had a bit too much
feta for their own good, hurling themselves
down a nearly vertical hill in pursuit of
a wheel of cheese.
It may sound a bit Emmental but it's a real
sport, and it's called cheese rolling.
It take's place every year in Gloucester,
England.
So what's the point of all this, surely there's
enough cheese in Gloucester to go around.
Well apparently not, the lucky winner, that's
the person that can chuck their limp bodies
down the hill the fastest, get's to the keep
the wheel of cheese.
But you can have too much of a Gouda thing.
Okay that's enough of the cheese jokes, but
in all seriousness, broken arms and legs are
extremely commonplace during the cheese rolling
event.
It may look like fun, but next time you're
thinking of throwing your body down a hill
after a wheel of cheese, remember, it's a
good deal safer to just go out and buy one.
For a long time people would look up to skydivers,
calling them daredevils or brave pioneers.
But then in 1978 some daring psychopath went
and jumped straight off a cliff wearing nothing
but a track suit and a small parachute on
their back, and made all the other daredevils
look a bit silly.
That daring man was called Carl Boenish and
he was the catalyst for a new breed of sport
known as BASE jumping, a sport which is growing
rapidly in popularity and involves parachuting
from any fixed structure.
The name, BASE jumping is an acronym that
stands for the four categories of fixed objects
which BASE jumping regularly throw themselves
off: Building, antenna, span, and earth.
That last one doesn't literally involve hurling
one's self off the face of the Earth, in BASE
jumping, Earth refers to cliffs.
As you can probably imagine the sport is fraught
with danger and fatalities are common.
Since the sport started there have been over
250 recorded deaths from BASE jumping.
When BASE jumping, technical precision and
solid planning is essential to staying alive,
the slightest mistake, such as steering in
the wrong direction for a second, or even
a strong gust of wind, or if you simply pull
your parachute open a second too late you
will die.
This is not for the faint hearted.
Next up is Buzkashi, literally meaning "goat
grabbing".
This sport is played in Central Asia, particularly
in Afghanistan where it as actually the national
sport.
It was brought to Afghanistan by Genghis Khan's
Mongol hordes 800 years ago.
Buzkashi is quite simple, all you need to
play is a pony and a dead goat, oh and twenty
fearless Afghanis who aren't afraid to get
seriously hurt.
The goal of Buzkashi is to fight over the
goat carcass, called a buz, and drag it towards
a goal.
Games are long and can sometimes last for
several days.
But they are also as brutal as they are long.
There are few rules and players hit opponents
often and hard, to try and dismount them or
get the goat carcass from them.
Players are usually equipped with whips, which
they not only use on their own horse, but
the opponent's horses and the opponents themselves.
It's an extremely brutal sport but it's not
just the players that get injured on a regular
basis.
Bukashi games often attract crowds in the
thousands and spectators are at much risk
as the players are themselves.
Several times a game you can expect players
to be flown from their horses and their horses
to go careering to the ground, often into
the crowd.
Spectators therefore have to be constantly
on their guard to avoid being flattened or
trampled on by a horse.
Or knocked out by a flying player.
There's no denying that American Football
is a dangerous sport.
Any sport where you have to wear a helmet
is sure to end in catastrophe.
Since 1931 there have been 1,027 recorded
deaths from American Football, mostly due
to catastrophic brain injuries from players
smacking their helmets into one another.
But American Football is not quite as dangerous
as the sport which is came from - Rugby.
Imagine American Football without the hard
helmets, face masks, shoulder pads, and basically
every other form of protection.
Rugby player typically wear little or no padding,
and any form of hard protective gear is banned.
Rugby is a rough contact sport and to participate
you pretty much have to be built like a tank,
so if you're no wider than a plank of wood
expect to get knocked into the dirt often
and painfully, especially when you're up against
this lot.
The two leading causes of death in rugby are
concussion and drowning, no it's not played
underwater, but unfortunately players can
sometimes drown in the mud if they're trapped
face down at the bottom of a pile up, which
in rugby is called a ruck.
Next up is boxing, there's no prize for guessing
why boxing is dangerous.
Boxing basically consists of 50% getting hit
in the face by a well trained killing machine
and the other 50% trying not to get hit in
the face.
Obviously it's a brutal sport, but just how
dangerous is it?
Well a professional boxer can punch with up
to 1,400 pounds per square inch of pressure.
That's enough power to accelerate their opponents
head at a rate of 53g, that's 53 times the
force of gravity.
A punch with that much force can cause all
sorts of issues, such as detached retinas,
brain haemorrhages, fractured skulls and permanent
neurological disorders such as dementia.
Between 1918 and 1997 there were at least
650 recorded deaths from professional boxing.
And finally is Horseback riding.
But surely beating people with sticks or jumping
off buildings is more dangerous than horseback
riding?
Well no, it may come as a surprise, but riding
a horse is probably the most dangerous sport
you can possibly do.
Horseback riding is not just about little
men jumping over wooden blocks and occasionally
going flying into a muddy puddle.
There's a lot more to equestrianism than meets
the eye.
Just staying on top of a horse is a difficult
task in itself, contrary to popular belief
you can't use your hands or legs to balance
on a horse because the rider uses those to
communicate with the horse, so you have to
balance on top of a 550 kg animal traveling
at speeds of up to 70 km/h using only your
buttocks to balance.
Statistics say that every horse rider can
expect a serious injury for every 350 hours
of riding.
But it's not just the high frequency of injuries
that makes it dangerous, it's the seriousness
of these injuries which is truly shocking.
Horseback riders can their spinal cords snapped
cleanly in two from a fall or their skulls
crushed under a horses hoof, and that's just
whilst riding the horse.
Horses can be unpredictable and whilst they're
not riding them, riders face the constant
threat of being kicked by a horse without
warning.
A horse's kick can exert up to 2,000 pounds
of pressure per square inch.
In fact horses have been known to kick holes
in stable walls with minimal effort.
Horseback riding can be dangerous for the
horses too, if a horse sustains an injury
whilst racing, such as a broken leg, because
horses are extremely expensive animals to
maintain, the injured horse is usually euthanised.